[Music]
joining me today is an author the
editorial director of the American
Institute for Economic Research as well
as a senior fellow at the Austrian
economic center Jeffrey Tucker welcome
to the Rubin report thanks for having me
good to be here I almost wore the same
bowtie my friend really I should have
brought one extra for you yeah that
would have been work on this all right
there's a ton I want to talk to ya
you're sort of one of these people that
are right around all of the topics that
I'm talking about from freedom and
liberty and free speech and the battle
between the left and the right and all
that but your new book and I want to get
the title absolutely correct right wing
collectivism the other threat to Liberty
I thought that would be the spot for us
to kick this off because most of the
people watching the show know that I've
mostly focused on the left sure yeah was
my home I was a progressive I've woken
up to what I shouldn't real liberalism
is obviously and that has nothing to do
with the modern life but sometimes
people say Dave you don't critique the
right enough so let's dive in what's
interesting about talk about it is that
so often the left and the right are not
as distinguishable as they seem to be
for example the this trade stuff you
know Elizabeth Warren and Donald Trump
basically agreed yeah you know how do
you account for that and and now will
you see all the celebration of the
working classes you know you're gonna
get again the trumpian right agreeing
with Bernie Sanders on that the left is
evermore trending nationalist and it's
immigration policies for example that
didn't use to be the case so how is the
left well you know listen well like
Bernie Sanders complained that free free
immigration is is a coke a Koch
Industries plot basically to provide the
capitalist class cheap workers for
example now that you would have never
found anybody on the Left 20 years ago
saying that but but now you know it's
happening you know the the the the the
hatred of the of Commerce and and the
the merchant class is so intense now
that if a luxury resort and
in Florida wants to hire soon some
immigrants to work for them then the
left is saying oh no this is this is
terrible because this cab this
capitalism at work so here's trying to
see the strange blending the left and
the right have different cultural
pitches different appeals different
constituencies but they both have this
this agenda that's that boils down to
the to the use of power is this a little
bit of just what people refer to as the
horseshoe theory that the more that the
sides have become sort of extreme that
they're oddly that may be right I've
heard this this horseshoe thing I tend
to think that's a little bit superficial
I mean I look at it a little bit more
historically and you see since since
liberalism was born in the world in the
18th century really light Middle Ages
but when the revolt against liberalism
began in the early 19th century right
too much change too much wealth the
wrong people are getting rich there's
not enough control what are we going to
do about our religion our language our
race you know this the revolt began to
grow from about the 1820s and and
intensified and spread to the United
States Britain really began to take root
in continental Europe there took two
forms there was a left form and a right
form and at each country they took they
took on different iterations different
names you know so so in Britain you had
the Tories then you had the labor labor
party they both wanted to use the state
for their own purposes then you always
had the opposition party which is the
Liberals you know and and that's the way
it's fleshed out itself in country after
country the Liberal Party has always
been the people said why don't we just
let society be let people live their
lives let them choose a religion of
their own of their own choice if they
don't hurt anybody it's not a problem
let's have free speech this have
universal rights that's how rights for
this get rid of slavery let's have
rights acknowledge the existence of
women's rights equality of freedom for
everybody leave everybody alone
that's the liberal position that's a
pretty good position it's a it's a
beautiful position and it's what I
favorites what I think it's what built
civilization coming out of the religious
wars of the high middle ages we
discovered this idea of freedom we tried
it it worked
but there's but there's a brief there's
always been a revolt brewing against it
a resentment resentment against it again
resentment against the commercial class
too much change too much wealth wrong
people getting wealthy we're not
controlling demographics well enough
there's not enough equality whatever the
thing is it takes different forms in
different countries and at different
times in different places but ultimately
the right and the left are ideologies of
control and power and liberalism has
always been the alternative to that so
so we keep having to rediscover this
again and again in every generation yeah
well that's why now I'm so happy that
there is as you said to me right before
we started the phrase classical
liberalism now is coming back you know
you mean you had it on TV every now and
again I like to think that maybe I had a
little something to do with it you know
and meaning to me
it is the only current antidote to the
problems that we have either the the
more state power that the Democratic
socialists want as they've sort of
ransacked their own party and purged all
of the Liberals and it's also the
antidote for all of the people if you
think Trump is all of the horrible
things that people say about him all
time what's the antidote
the antidote isn't to get somebody else
in that more power yeah the antidote
obviously is to take power away from
that that's what liberalism and I my
hope is that that there are the good
people who left the center of the left
that are looking at the emergence of the
Trump problem will reconsider the uses
of power and the executive state and why
do we build this gigantic machinery of
the total state if it's so vulnerable to
being captured by our enemies right
right the real question that we're at
right now if you believe this thing has
been captured by the Russians or
whatever it is it's like yeah well okay
yeah and answering your own question I
hope that we can we can rekindle a kind
of a new resurgence or I do have to
credit you and Jordan Peterson for this
I mean I've been working at it for about
ten years to try to bring back this not
just the term liberal but the concept of
the brill ism
- to public life and but it's been
difficult because because because we do
have this state that creates a kind of
moral and intellectual and ideological
hazard
somebody's got to control it and and now
that we built it over the last hundred
years this this this total state of
massive taxes regulations interventions
run in people's lives everybody's trying
to get hold of it and grab it and beat
up their enemies and it's a problem it's
a serious problem so when people say to
me and we've discussed this on the show
a bunch of times before and I've dressed
address this in several forums when
people say to me wait a minute when
you're when you say you're a classical
liberal you talk about lazy for
economics and getting the government out
of the way and all those things really
this is just a repackaged libertarianism
or you're just afraid to say that you're
a conservative because it's still not
cool
or something that is how would you
define the difference between say
classical liberal and a libertarian
let's talk about that because because
after World War two these neologisms
these new terms came along one was
conservatism it wasn't really used
before the early 1950s Russell Kirk's
book called the mindset of a
conservative something like the
conservative mind I think is what it was
called and libertarianism was again
first used at about 1957 by the
translator of the works of Basquiat the
problem was the term liberal had been
captured you know by the new dealers
mmm-hmm as early as 1933 once they
acquiesced to the idea of the corporate
of a state andr blame the Great
Depression on capitalism that became a
problem for liberalism that kept the
term liberalism but they were no longer
liberal because they were suddenly for
big government here before big
government and and even worse the
corporate state and actually we can just
be more blunt about it and say that back
in the 1930s is this this ideology had a
name the name is fascist yeah okay so so
they caved right I mean in the New York
Times in 1933 the New York Times
magazine was celebrating the great
professor Mussolini
and how he and FDR shared a vision for
the planned economy so that's the world
we were living in back then so we lost
the term liberal after World War 2 there
was an attempt to to just speak language
and to and to describe who we are and on
one hand you had this new thing called
conservatism and they they they kind of
sampled some of the story
Tory like nostalgia for the past a
little bit of revanche ISM you know
let's recapture what we've lost didn't
you on the other hand who had the
genuine liberals and they coined the
term libertarianism which had been
sitting on the shelf since the late 19th
century now most of the people who call
themselves libertarians in the late 19th
century America and England were
anarchists socialists but nobody had
bothered with the term for decades and
decades
so Dean Russell said well nobody's using
that word why don't we use it and that
was closer to the truth of what they
were in effect well what was interesting
about that is as Dean Russell described
it in his 1957 article it was a synonym
for what was once called liberal right
he didn't think it was a tweak or an
improvement or a distillation or
refinement or a new dogmatic way of
describing the bill ISM he thought it
was liberalism so I need to read that
because I mean that's how I feel I don't
know if someone says me Dave you're a
libertarian I don't mind that if we need
labels I don't mind that lame I don't
mind you know we can split the
difference on how much government sure
should be so the problem I think
libertarianism has a number as a term as
the other problems one is it's a little
clinical sounding and it has too many
syllables and it makes you sound a
little bit awkward and it sounds maybe a
little too canonical you know like we we
have a list of things you have to
believe you know like this this this
it's all rooted in this kind of
reductionist more commonly these days
that's rooted in this kind of in the
reductionist non-aggression principle
which is a fine principle as a rule of
thumb but it's not a good it doesn't
describe the whole of life so the other
problem is that libertarianism is is a
new term so it doesn't have a deep
history so we can't look back
and say oh look the libertarians freed
the slaves the libertarians acknowledge
to the rights of women the the
libertarians gave us the commercial
society that built the middle class and
brought dignity to the average person
right if they had existed as a party
they would have done those they would
have done those yeah where's the
Liberals who did that but it delivers so
we changed our name so now we can't like
feel a sense of pride in our past so it
doesn't have a past hmm that's a problem
so we're libertarians tend to be
detached from their own history for that
reason and I think it's a it's a problem
as a word problem the second problems
that libertarianism doesn't have a
universal of usage like where's
liberalism does you can go to Spain
describe yourself in liberal Brazil
there's there's liberals in Germany
there's liberals Everett there's a word
for liberalism in every language and it
more or less means the same thing except
in the United States right so so if we
acquiesce to this term libertarian and
just wipe out our liberal history we're
cutting ourselves off both from the
world and from our own history it's so
funny because you've just said it in a
far better way than I think I've ever
really laid it out but people will say
to me Dave stop saying you're a liberal
and I don't want to stop saying them I
get that I'm fighting an uphill battle
right now right I'm a salmon swimming
upstream this is gonna be tough but I
don't want to deny what is the truth
just because because it's tough it's who
you are
and you want to you want to have it an
ancestry you know you want to look back
and and see the the champions of the
meta cheese and and 15th century
Florence and say I know those people
those are my people yeah you know the
people who long for a world without
slavery you know in the early 19th
century the people who wanted world free
trade and fought hard for it those are
our people that's our history I mean we
were we were born as part of a long
stream of emancipation that's been
taking place for 500 years that's our
movement our people our history let's
embrace it I'm with you brother yeah all
right so are there any of those
liberals part of the Democratic Party
anymore
do those people exist that's strange
things are happening on the left very
strange things and I I'm not sure I
should applaud you for one sec I have my
original question here was I wanted to
do the deep dive on the right so we're
gonna go we will get no I promise you
we're gonna get to them yeah the deep
dive on the far right gets us into a
very dark place yeah all right well
maybe that night so maybe the whole
second half will be on that let me just
put that out there right now that's what
we'll do really sighs it's not getting
out of my depression having my book it
was terrible all right so our whole
second half is gonna be what my first
question was about let's just keep going
on yeah out for now so so strange things
have happened to the left let's just
mention that the the phrase cultural
appropriation for example now when when
did that the approbation of the Society
of cultural appropriation came out over
what two three years ago you know four
five I don't know academia is weird it
may have been brewing for ten years yeah
but when I first heard about it I
thought that is the craziest bunch of
nonsense I've ever heard I mean
civilization is nothing but cultural
appropriation has been doing this since
since the 9th century you know at the
height of the comfo Vincey omits in
Spain where different Judaism and Islam
and Christianity came together in this
beautiful melting pot where we all learn
from each other and the cultures began
to blend and our religions began to
change in our our outlook on life began
to because we learn from each other if
we stay isolated in our little tribes
we're never gonna progress and and and
the idea that and I don't know if it was
inadvertent or what happened we can talk
about this but that when when suddenly
you're told you cannot have affection
for another culture and take what you
find valuable and and learn learn for
yourself and live a better life that is
very strange they seem to think it's
cultural annihilation not cultural
appropriation right like they seem to
know that this is something that will
lead to the destruction of that culture
when in fact yeah it actually spreads
the ideas of the culture the foods that
were losing the the ideas not just
they're generating culture
as a scarce good like it's a property
but it's not the magic of culture which
is the same magic of ideas is resides in
its infinite reproducibility and its
malleability this is something that the
world of ideas can do that the physical
world cannot do and if we don't make
that distinction we're gonna get very
confused do you see what I mean and
cultures spread and they're infinite and
they can constantly change and that's
the magic and beauty of culture we can't
get that out of this glass of water this
table right there they're bound by the
constraints of scarcity but the world of
ideas is as magical it's like a constant
constant infinite sandstorm you know
unpredictable and and constantly
changing and we can we can take a
culture for ourselves without taking it
from somebody else right it's just it's
it's it's reproductive reproduction it's
infinite reproduction so loaves and the
fishes
isn't isn't the beauty to that America
has done this better than anyone
perhaps in the history of the world you
just references some other points in
time but that we have taken in more
cultures and you said the phrase melting
pot I mean that that's what we designed
and set up here the most beautiful
melting pot ever I lived in New York
City for most of my life most of my
adult life at least and would be on
subway cars and you are on that car
with absolutely everyone with I have
white guys with dreadlocks and the whole
thing and guess what you may not like
everybody and you may not like the way
this guy smells and that person may be
doing this but we're all there and I
live in together it's magic you know
it's it's it really it's commerce it's
because this country elevated the
commercial ethos to be the the highest
thing the great ennobling factor of
human life and its commerce that brings
people together and we experience that
every day you know you can in a
commercial setting people aren't
fighting each other they're they're
getting along I mean I I find I'm with
you I go to that I go to a restaurant
and I get served by some guy from
from Pakistan it's it it's a chance to
meet somebody new it's a chance to
engage somebody to have a personal
relationship with somebody who's serving
you and you're serving them and you
experience this magic of exchange
Benjamin constant used to talk about
this and the 1830's how how how commerce
brought to the world a new understanding
of freedom and a new opportunity for us
to find value in each other in service
of each other and can America just
flourished in commerce and that's why
that's why we have you know the the
diversity and this melting pot you call
it and this rich cultural life you know
it's so funny because I'm so keenly
aware of it right now not only because
of the conversations I'm having and
because people are screaming about this
stuff all the time but you know I'm on
this tour with Jordan Pederson and when
I go to every airport that I go to a 90
percent of the time unless someone said
a car for me I take an uber and it's hop
in whatever rubra shows and there is
there there is every single type of
person that looks every which way and
every little or every sexuality and
usually I talk a little bit to them it
you know and it's like man these are
just people I've you know I'm maybe for
the same way you know I live in Atlanta
which is just a gigantically diverse
society you know and everywhere you go
you're bumping into people who are
different from you and and hang around
in crypto circles in Atlanta I want to
yeah yeah and and that you talk about a
melting pot I mean we're all together
and there we all consider each other our
people you know just because we all love
crypto today and it has nothing to do
with with race you can appreciate racial
differences with but also see value in
everybody and and hope they can see
value in you you can come together it
doesn't mean that we have to be
egalitarian or deny differences it means
that we find strength in our
heterogeneity and and that's that makes
for a beautiful and exciting life one of
the strangest things is happening now
you know with the rise of the alt-right
in response to the failures and and
strangeness of the left is this new
celebration of homogeneity
we need to live in a unitary racial
state you know where we all speak the
same language or all of the same
religion so that strikes me as
aesthetically very boring and I don't I
don't even recognize what that world
would look like and feel like and it
doesn't appeal to me in the slightest
bit yeah Minerva it was built out of the
out of the diversity that grows out of
Commerce and the commerce is the key
because that's what helps us invest in
each other you know Adam Smith said this
about the division of labor right it's
like what causes wealth the division of
labor how big can that be it should be
as big as possible the wider the
division of labor the more people you
include in the great project of a
building commercial life and production
the wealthier we're all going to be
together and I just I love that vision
so when we talk about capitalism others
show I'll every now and again I jump in
the comment section or I see what people
say on Twitter if I have you know some
of the Iran people on or just some of
the people that are not for a regulation
oh and just let the economy go and see
what happens there's always a certain
amount of people that say okay that all
sounds well and good but then the rich
just keep getting richer and the poor
keep getting poorer and Jeff Bezos
shouldn't have you know 20 trillion
dollars or whatever he has right now or
the rest of it what's the what's the
boilerplate answer to why he ventured it
over those kind of cliches because I've
been they've been around for 150 years
and they're never untrue
I mean that would they weren't true and
Marx this time and everybody you know
quickly recognized that you know by the
late 19th century in America we had we
had built the most prosperous economy in
the world by far by far by far growing
incomes longer lives healthier people
more opportunities for everybody people
are moving to the cities everybody's
benefiting from capitalism that's been
going on for such a long time again here
we are in 2018 and we're still recycling
these this Victorian era
it's about capitalism I don't understand
it what do you think capitalism then
screwed up if if only just a marketing
piece of it or something where right now
you sense and I believe that it will not
win it that it somehow doesn't seem cool
to be for capitalism at least with you
to be the change maybe it's in the name
and I did I don't even have a problem
not using them the word capitalism I
mean I would probably have the same view
towards this I will speak the language
that that you can understand and if I
want to rebrand capitalism as liberalism
which it probably should be actually
liberal liberalism then I'm glad to talk
about that the same time I kind of like
the term capitalism I have no problem
with it because because it really does
underscore a really important point that
without private-property in the in the
end ownership of the means of production
you can't have a complex production
structures and you can't hire more
people you can't you can't build great
things you can't have great cities you
can't improve people's lives so what are
the things that you think government
should do well I think of lots of
cleansing rules that we should have but
I'm not a fan of governments in general
if there was some way that you could
have you know an old-fashioned liberal
state you know that was really minded
his own business and kept kept civil war
from happening for example you know kept
conflict that kind of mass conflict then
that would be a probably a good good
thing state is not very good at that so
I think I mean I've got I've got the
mind of an anarchist essentially I trust
you know I trust the chaos of of
spontaneous human action much more than
any kind of imposition yeah but but I am
at the same time I do like the writings
of the old liberals you know they they
imagine that the state should do
something to keep something like a order
in life to keep civil war from happening
to keep people from killing each other
terrible things like that but beyond
that state should just it should be less
a fair I should just allow commerce to
flourish and allow law problems to work
themselves out I and people don't have
confidence in that anymore
but not because of any failure but it's
almost like the ideology of power has
become a kind of a modern
cancer that affects afflicts everyone
and I think we need to do something
about it
wait can you explain that a little bit
well it's just a once you believe that
you can control the path of history and
you have an endpoint in mind society
should look like this then you want to
use every kind of tool to hammer it in
place and this is this is what I call
right and left wing Hegelian ISM
essentially and it's it's a grave
temptation and so we built this like we
said at the outset and we built this
gigantic machinery we call the state
this total state and it controls so much
wealth and so much power and so much
rests with with getting you know gaining
access to it that it's just a kind of a
constant moral hazard for everybody like
give me that state and I'll make it do
the right things right so for the people
that on either side of this whether
you're on the left and you want to help
those that you deem oppressed more
people with less when I believe their
intentions to be good even if their
methodology I think generally is not
good or your people on the right that
want less of a state but you know you're
just on either side of this thing how
much do you think the the system itself
can move without breaking because what I
think I'm noticing now is that there's a
certain amount of people that really
just want to trash the whole thing and I
do see this certainly more on the left
right now because they're not in power
then there's this growing thing and this
is why they're so into Marxism and all
this stuff now it's like let's just
trash the whole freaking thing and
forget all the goodness that this is
done and they're doing it from their
iPhones and you know their sense of
irony is not great but if there is their
system you mean right now is there just
a certain amount that a system that's
basically good can move before it snaps
and I would suspect that it's not much
either way really you mean the the
commercial structure right now or our
lives our capitalist leaders we mean the
state you know what I see actually
happening is the innovation has taken
place so quickly it's actually
outrunning the the capacity of
government to control it and I think
that's that's really exciting if I was
gonna look at one point of hope in the
world is that the the market
the entrepreneurial innovative sectors
of life from the app economy to the gig
economy to now with with blockchain
technology and everything is moving so
quickly that states can't can't even
keep up all right so I'm there with you
on that because I Laureus I'm very happy
about that I see that because it's to me
it's like how are people listening to
all of these conversations all of these
podcasts that are out there and
communicating about them so quickly and
it's like the government can't know it
can't keep up with all of that the
change can't because people are lighting
up all the time now in a much faster way
and I think we're changing in a much
more rapid way and I think that's
actually really cool there's a danger to
it because we could just spin out of
control and do all sorts of awful things
but what you said well what did you say
before about the general inertia of
people or something that the general
left to their own ways of figuring
things out I'll figure it out and you
know there's a reason why our politics
seem reactionary on the left and the
right everyone's trying to bring back
something there's there's a nostalgia on
the left and a nostalgia on the right
and they're trying to use the state to
hold us back
like and and whatever it's a vision of
the is that the sixties is it is it the
seventies is it pre-industrial
revolution you know is that some reso
Ian fantasy and perfect equality in oh
that the left might imagine or or or the
right thinking about you know a world of
high tariffs of the 1880s or nineties or
but everyone's looking back to something
they want to create and it's there's a
real fear of the future on the left on
the right and it's a future without
control it's a future where we're able
to travel where we want to download the
apps we want to invent what we want to
work by ourselves live where we want to
live be digital nomads you know travel
around do it we want this this world
that's so cool that's not what people
should be fearing people everyone should
be going holy cow this is the freest
coolest thing ever that's the world I
want to live in that Matt obviously is
why you're so attracted to Bitcoin also
right and crypto general sure which is
sort of the the backbone
I mean if you think about it I mean
we've waited our whole lives and
actually generations of great
intellectuals have lived lived and died
for so long
wanting something like a private
currency that that emerged privately
that operates without financial
intermediaries that the government is
not controlling that's global that
doesn't it's not restrained by currency
zones that anyone could have access to
you know a true democratic technology
like Bitcoin or any cryptocurrency that
is just a dream come true
that is glorious that's why I write
about it all the time and talk about it
all the time
it is it is the alt-right killer it is
the alt left killer it's it's the thing
that's going to ultimately I think
protect us from these wicked ideologies
that are constantly trying to control
their lives because basically at some
point one of these ideologies is going
to get too much control of the state
just fine each other forever I mean you
know one of the things that I think
about this sometimes when you get
depressed about the divisions in our
public life and the way people are
tearing you're tearing each other apart
and the way you open up the newspaper in
the city you can barely even read it
anymore yeah you know it was like yeah I
know I know but it's like down the Trump
you know then just like a know up with
Trump you know and it's just it's just
this forever debate and the one thing
that I think maybe we should not be
entirely unhappy about this is you look
back at history when when freedom
emerges out of the high middle ages it
wasn't because any one great
intellectual or any one great state or
any one great power said hey let's let
everybody be free it was because there's
so many competitors for power that they
nobody could could gain the monopoly it
was the church it was the the
nation-state it was the the locality of
some monarchical state that the landed
aristocracy you know the the rising
merchant class you know so they're all
these independent power centers strewn
throughout European society and nobody
can get get access to the final single
singular control no unitary power and so
that fight that took place among so many
disparate powers actually led to a kind
of flourishing of freedom so you know
in a sense the fight between the left
and the right today is not the worst
thing if they just keep fighting and
leave the rest of us alone that lucky
but okay so before we spend the whole
second half on the question that I
started this whole thing with the people
who want freedom basically and a light
touch of government are they always at a
disadvantage because there's another set
of people who will always use the
apparatus against them where if they're
being true to themselves they won't use
the power to stifle other people or all
sorts of other things so in an odd way
our ideas are at a dissident always have
been we've always been a kind of
minority so even again over the last two
three hundred years of political history
we've always been that that third way
that's my minority but we had we had
rare victories but big ones you know
like the end of slavery you know was
just glorious I mean the protection of
the great banking empires of Europe from
from the populist rabble you know from
the from the preachers who wanted to
destroy it there were these great
victories the victory of free trade you
know but but we've won every one swell
and it always changed the world because
once you have a little bit of freedom
just a little bit it just blows up and
it becomes awesome and it's amazing it
and it and it kills power because it's
so powerful and so wonderful but it's
worth fighting for and we've always
fought mainly through ideas not through
armies not through through guns and
controlling States has always been the
philosophical awesomeness of this
position has been the celebration of the
common man the celebration of wealth the
the love of consumerism and commercial
life or the coming together of people
the ennoble ment of people that the the
right of travel the right of association
and to do what you want to have as many
children as you want to to educate your
kids the way you want to that these
kinds of principles are compelling and
they've always led to victory for
liberals despite the pressure from the
other two sides and I think that's I
think it's gonna be our future I do
let's shift let's talk about the scary
right are you ready I tried to do this
we did the happiest
we're gonna plunge look you know Dave
when I began to research this thing I
probably ended up reading about 200
books on this topic
why the end and and I'm a happy guy I
like happy things I like technology I'm
an optimistic guy but this really put me
in a dark place digging through this
history from from Hegel essentially up
to Julius Caesar Avila and the and the
post-war Nazi movement and realizing
that there is an intellectual strain
that stretched over all of these years
okay so let lets over 200 years
yeah so let's go back 200 years when you
talk about right-wing collectivism yep
because I think most of my audience now
understands what left-wing collectivism
is because that's what we've got right
now very in a very strong way talk to me
about right-wing collectivism okay David
I gotta tell you a story
I love ludivine Mises I think he was a
genius right and I thought I'd read all
of his works but and there was a
transcript of a lecture he gave in 1956
at the San Francisco Public Library and
he had about three sentences in there
that just knocked me over and I couldn't
believe it it cuz they explained so much
he says something like this and he's
speaking casually right
he says Hegel ruined German philosophy
for a century
his original followers became believed
that all of history would end in the
Prussian state and the Prussian Church
having all power and the end of
individualism they became the right
Hegelians that became the Nazis his the
dissidents of this of the right
Hegelians became the left to galleons
they wanted a universal transformation
of humanity and a historical drive to to
something other than the commercial
society they became the Marxists and and
the Communists and he said that that's
its left-right he galleon ISM and that
explains pretty much all the political
history and I close that I thought no
that explains more than practically any
other book I've ever read and so I began
to begin to explore this I understood
the lefty Gallienus I understood Marxism
I mean those were those were our
professors right and they're annoying
but what I did not understand was the
right Hegelian ISM and what that what
that tradition looks like is that the
throne and altar this this hysteresis
view that the nation should constitute
its own unit of profound integrity that
that that is more important than the
individual and that commercial society
was too chaotic that it that that it was
leading us giving us the wrong kind of
progress that it was flattening out the
hierarchies that we need to have an
orderly life right this is this is the
right Hegelian pitch that ultimately by
mid 20th century becomes this very
dangerous dangerous movement in Europe
you know it became catastrophic but it
gradually emerged from all the way from
from Hegel because this is at the the
end of the endless seemingly endless
franco-prussian war there's this battle
at the Battle of Jena that that Germany
lost and the explanation for that was
that it was a temporary setback that
history was going to determine that
Germany would rise just despite despite
the choices of individuals history has
got its wind it's like meta-narrative
that that that was gonna override
everything Hegel himself was a
theologian by the way and so and so this
this view began to kind of spread
throughout German academia and it was it
ended up being imported to the United
States through through circuitous means
but one of the great theorists of the of
the 1840s who and 1850s who brought this
you to the United States was Frederick
Liszt who was one of the first
economists to repudiate the free trade
tradition of the smithy in Manchester
IDEs and now was celebrating the nation
as a unit as a productive power and and
believed in tariff walls which was
strange and of ridaz book
but and that had a huge influence of
American trade policies actually the
late 19th century and and it began to
flow from there so Thomas Carlyle and
and and Britain now begins to celebrate
the great man theory of history and
really were nothing without Napoleon
without without gigantic figures that we
can worship admire and and and ours
individuality should be subsumed within
them they act for us their godlike you
know and and and it was Thomas Carlyle
who first coined the phrase quote coined
the phrase to describe acute economics
as being the dismal science and the
reason he said that is that every
economist he knew imagined a world
without slavery and he said you can't
have a world South slavery that's that's
a dreadful world without slaves you
don't have masters right and we need a
world with masters and slaves so we can
we can have a vision of hierarchy and
greatness without that we don't have
greatness so you begin to see this
building of this intellectual apparatus
it was not left to galleon there wasn't
Marxist he was actually anti-marxist in
our strange way but as an alternative
form of collectivism it began with a
kind of a historicism and a celebration
on nationalism of the German state it
began to grow with this there's this
alternative theory of trade that we
should we should build up tariff walls
and Carlyle with his with his great man
theory of history and then and then
Ruskin and and Britain with his hatred
of commercial society because they
believed that somehow
commerce was ruining quality and culture
and was giving us mass production about
we all need to be really doing this is
is living in guilds and and making our
own stuff you know because we're gonna
destroy English life and English country
life and so so a full-scale reactionary
trend on the right began to develop and
we're always a racial element you know
so that's what's interesting I'm so glad
you asked that because it comes about
first of all through through nationalism
now in the in the early 1820s and 1830s
this the celebration of nationalism
you have to ask yourself what is a
nation but what do we mean when we say
nation and and I'm taking this a lot of
this from from an S I gave it given to
1882 by Ernst ran in a great French
historian looking back at the rise of
nationalism said there's only five ways
you can consider nationalism we consider
the geographic definition so we're just
living the space there's a dynastic
element we can all trace our lineage
back to the great founders of our our
nation there's a language theory of
nationalism we all speak the same
language there's a religious theory of
nationalism we all worship God and a
precise assembly I believe in
transubstantiation do you believe in
consubstantiation we can't be part of a
nation in that case right and then
finally and probably most insidiously
there was a racial the racial view and
that came along and essentially the
1860s and 1870s with a misapplication of
Darwinian theory and scientific racism
came along and that swept through
academia particularly in the United
States like nothing you've ever seen it
was absolutely astonishing how much
racism with orthodoxy and American
academia in the 1890s from the very
first monograph published by the
American Economic Association by a game
I think his name is Andre Hoffman was
called race traits of the American Negro
and the first chapter dress goes all in
you know it's it's it's the the horror
of the black people they don't have the
right values they can't can't save money
that was terrible
shiftless and lazy and ghastly and
uncivilized Abel and now chapter 2 the
Jews you know these people I don't know
what they've got this crazed out of
control commercial ethic they can't stop
hoarding money they really went for it
yeah and then chapter 3 is the slop
sense and so on and so the American
Economic Association you know and then
and there was essentially no what do you
think was happening in the world there
that it was taking tiny blobs
opening day let's say fair had
transformed society so dramatically that
the the intellectuals felt that they had
lost control now you might think that
when the world becomes massively
prosperous and we suddenly have cities
rising up and we've got steel that's
transversing large bodies of water and
we're developing the telephone and
indoor electricity and and people are
living longer lives and and so much
wealth is being created that everybody
was data to say Hawaii we've found the
answers but the gatekeepers who had
controlled everything for so long so
that's so interesting because revolt
this is sort of what it feels like now
to me the gatekeepers we've had so much
success
there's someone there's so many reasons
right now to understand how great
everything is that book right there by
Steven Pinker and light mr. right book
is is all about how great things are and
that's a gratefully where there is less
violence now in all sorts of the revolt
you always have to be on the but the
gatekeepers aren't having you know not
in the narrative intellectuals are what
beautiful classic calls the Clara see
right so it's it's the the high-end
intellectuals it's the power elite
bureaucrats and and the public the the
permanent people keepers of our civic
culture you know it's it's the political
class and so this is sort of what my
audience that maybe not family all this
this is sort of what the New York Times
is sort of right like yeah maybe I
shouldn't have said it so obviously but
like that's kind of what it is like that
class a ruling class yeah the ruling
class and and they were in full-scale
revolt oh they did not like what was
happening to the world in the 1880s and
90s because of the loss of control and
so the the scientific racism came along
to add to the celebration of
dictatorship and the end and
protectionism and the new nationalism to
add a very insidious element which
culminated in eugenics ideology and
that's when it gets very strange and
this is where this is where they're
reading gets very difficult because now
you're reading all the way into your the
the the 1910s with the works of Oswald
Spengler you know the
the right hey galleon German theorist
and enraptured every American here
they're all reading his book oh my god
the decline of the West we better
reconstitute ourselves as a tribe or
we're gonna be eaten alive by the other
four and there's a strain of that that's
still going on right now you know
there's nothing new you're like and and
you know the this this very funny book
called the passing of the great race by
Madison grant that was on every coffee
table and the late nineteenth and early
1920s you know was was forecasting doom
for the white race you know when he was
he was a fascinating figure because you
know of course I British because as it
everybody did everybody the Great Gatsby
makes a passing reference to it it was
that popular it was that popular and I
tell you there's not a single outright
racist alive today who hasn't is not
repeating those cliches that were
written by Madison grant it's all
pseudoscience is all just nonsense and
it's just ridiculous embarrassing but
but it keeps being resurrected but
here's what's interesting
he was a thoroughgoing Darwinian because
she recall that Darwin had two great
books Origin of Species the other was
called The Descent of Man and The
Descent of Man had the very unfortunate
paragraph in there where he gret regrets
the invention of mass disease killing
Juris essentially it's like if we keep
curing people and we keep feeding
inferior people and and curing disease
then then our genetic stocks aren't
going to go down and down you know so so
they're all kind of playing off this
little bit of passage the Madison grant
was was not an unusual by American x to
academic standards at all they are they
this was a war that aux in the 1810 to
1920s what made Madison grant
interesting you can look up his
Wikipedia entry right now if you look it
up it'll it'll celebrate him as the as
the father of the National Park Service
well in the course of my research I
wanted to know what is the connection
between Madison's Grant's hardcore
eugenics based racism and its
environmentalism hmm what is the
relationship there and it's not just to
people usually people have haven't
figured out in their own heads I went
through and read some of his works on
him on the environment it turns out that
he had a master race theory of nature
and he went to the California Redwoods
and he looked at these glorious mighty
trees and he was horrified to see they
were being cut down for for making
coffee tables and boats and things like
that he thought it was this genic to
nature so he wanted the master race the
Calvin read words to to be protected and
that's that so that's why he started the
National Park Service and now the left
Harrelson is as this great as a great
visionary environmentalist but actually
he was like a tree Nazi I don't know how
you want to call it okay three nice it's
very creepy stuff we don't have enough
Nazi labels being thrown around now
we're gonna have tree not you ensure
that order he was nuts but you know you
can just march through the history and
it gets worse and worse and then to me
Dave it all it all culminates in the
works of cross MIT from the from the
late 1930s and is in his amazing book
called the concept of the political and
if you'll give me just one quick second
to explain this because because you as a
liberal I need to read this book because
it's the most passionate I would say an
even competent attack on liberalism
written in the twentieth century now
Carl Schmitt was a jurist a brilliant
man and a philosopher and a hardcore
Nazi okay he wasn't tried at Nuremberg
he escaped I'm merely an intellectual ok
sure his book concept of the political
says what's wrong with liberalism I tell
you it's dull nothing happens nothing
dramatic there's nothing just requires
no courage whatsoever liberalism is a
life in which we all benefit from each
other's presence we all just trade with
each other what kind of life is that
where we all just are kind of the same
and like each other and hope backyard
barbecues and baseball games and and
just get richer and live longer lives
and send our kid to college this is
terrible we need to live big dramatic
mighty bold courageous transformative
lives and live in times that that that
that that are shocking that are amazing
that make our lives worth living
that requires above all else politics
liberalism imagines a world without
politics that's a terrifying world what
we need is a world of politics and and
he continues to lay it out chapter by
chapter why we have to destroy
liberalism and celebrate the concept of
the political and for him that means
having friends and having enemies
defeating your enemies and rallying
around your friends now who are your
friends and who your enemies and Carl
Schmitt says at some level it doesn't
matter what matters is that they exist
and the end the state the powerful men
will choose them for us they will decide
who our friends and our enemies are now
let's be clear what we mean by enemy I
just don't mean somebody don't like I
mean the willingness to kill there has
to be the presence of real bloodshed in
your time for you to have a sufficiently
prescient sense of any meanness so that
you'll feel the intense desire to rally
around your friend for your friends and
experience that that the the awesomeness
that only comes with belonging to a
group so so he says so here at the end
the end feeling there is that you can't
achieve what what the real purpose of a
human is that's right that you can't
experience whatever the the highs of
belongingness essentially and and the
life of drama the a big important life
without being part of a kind of a group
on the move the slaughtering and enemies
and so we have to have the presence of a
bloodshed so it really is the opposite
of living letlet it is it so through
through through bloodshed comes life and
without without bloodshed and death and
violence and politics then you're just
gonna live at an irrelevant life and we
can't have that so he was in many ways
the philosophical architect of the
Holocaust
again not a leftist not a Marxist
although he dabbled in it you find this
a little from a lot of these right
collectivists the writer galleons that
they dabbled guys like Vernon her son
Bart right he was once a communist who
later became a Nazi Carl Schmitt dabbled
and and leftism and then went full right
and it was in many ways the culmination
of the writer galleon idea
and cross Schmidt so it'sit's a book
worth reading and contemplating and I
would say to anybody who rejects
liberalism you know be honest about
where you're going with this this is the
opposite of liberalism and celebration
of death in the works of Karl Schmidt
very powerful thinker highly regarded
even today worth reading and worth
reflecting on what kind of world do you
want to live in you want to live in at
peace with others what do you want to
slaughter your friends a slaughter your
enemies and rally with your friends so
move me from that point 1930s into of
course obviously into Nazi Germany and
then we'll so actually well yeah and and
you know my book really does end in 1950
and not necessarily didn't have to but I
started to get really queasy about what
happened after World War two a lot of
the right of yelling movement went
underground you know and and became a
kind of a quiet neo-nazi movement that
never really had access to social media
they were clear they weren't in academia
obviously and but the ideology never
entirely went away and and it was just
lying in wait wait waiting for the
failure of the left and for the
resentment of the population against the
left to rise up and receive who get a
fever enough pitch that it would it
would then come on full force and that's
really what's happening in Europe Russia
United States it's an alternative form
of collective isms got a different
flavor a different orientation a
different kind of resentments but it
still drags in this gigantic history of
writing guilty and ideology the
celebration of the dick great man
dictated the protectionism the
anti-immigration the nativism the
nationalism that could take any one of
five forms including the racism what do
you make about how now and it's
obviously largely because of the
Internet it seems to be happening in so
many places at once we're seeing this
unholy it's an oddly unholy alliance
that I've seen the collectivist left and
then that drives in minutes exactly what
you're saying then you've got this other
that's just waiting there for these guys
to go to bananas yeah it's like we got
all the easy answers meanwhile you have
the Liberals and every
all the decent 80% of us yeah that are
trying to live unless part of it part of
it really comes down to this there's a
weird a sociological cultural
contradiction at the heart of social
democratic leftist ideology on one hand
they they wanted to build gigantic
institutions that are redistributed to
worry and we're supposed to treat each
other like a big family and we're
supposed to have this homogeneous
nation-state on the other hand they're
celebrating diversity and encouraging
mass emigration and heterogeneous
populations and guess what those don't
really work together so you build
gigantic Institute dry ganic states that
presume sort of that we're all one
family and then you throw in this this
this diverse set of people especially
with the refugee crisis in Europe and
immigration in the United States and
people are looking around going oh these
people are my family I don't even like
these yeah
and yet I'm paying for them and that is
a prescription I mean that blows up I
mean that's a disaster it's a powder keg
and so is the left and there this core
contradiction that they have between on
welfare state on one hand and their
celebration and heterogeneous
populations on the other welfare state
and diversity they don't they don't work
and that basically puts us where Germany
sort of is at right now right where they
said okay three million people come on
in now all these people are gonna have
to pay for you we're not going to
integrate you proper I mean this is not
only now you've got to identitarian
movements rising up in Germany and in
Hungary and of course in Russia and and
of course the u.s. you know so it all
just kind of follows it's it's
inevitable the left created this I mean
if if after world war two we had just
embraced liberalism by we should have
like we should have we wouldn't be where
we are today but we have another chance
and that's why you're here and that's
why I'm here we have another chance now
to reimburse liberal liberal theory yeah
and to end to reject the left and don't
feel yourself just because the enemy of
your enemy is is there it doesn't mean
that has to be your friend I mean we
really do need to think of ourselves as
kind of a dissidents from a political
culture that that rally around freedom
and human rights and universal human
rights and and the annulment of humanity
the champion of the common person
the rights of everyone to live freely
with each other to gain value from each
other and to live in peace and stop
thinking of our fellow human beings as
possible enemies we don't want to get
drafted into this the political world
that call Schmidt imagine for us as I
was describing cross my you you see it
happening right that Schmidty in view to
slice and dice the population who do you
like who do you hate you know who are
your people it's this is not a good life
yeah and we feel like chopping away at
both sides right yeah we do we feel it
and so we don't I just don't feel like
we have to be part of it I mean as best
we can
let's find things we love yeah you know
I go places we love me with people we
love of all different backgrounds all
different kind of cultures learn about
alternative religions learn learn about
new ways to do things travel right and
the age of liberalism there were no such
things as passports you know all right
so let's let's spend the last portion
here on just these last five years
really here in America because I
remember just even doesn't have to be
the last five years but let's say even
three years ago just it's sort of the
emergence of Trump as a candidate when
people started saying the phrase all
right yeah and I did a bunch of videos
on it where I was basically saying I see
two strains to this thing and people are
now using this video against me and what
I saw was there was the sort of fun me
makers and the all of the people who
were having fun online doing often doing
awful things and Nazi imagery just to
upset people in power and whatever but
sometimes very fun things too and funny
things but I saw it like just the real
sort of [ __ ] posters as they're known
and the Peppe people the whole idea was
we could get we could start sending a
frog to some like intellectual and
they're gonna think that's a racist
thing and then they would say I'm being
under attack from racist he would
actually give them exactly what they
wanted so I saw this this sort of fun
[ __ ] posting whatever part of it not to
say it didn't have elements I didn't
like but there were I saw that as the
bulk of it and then along side of that
was this they're talking about the
identitarian part the true racist part
the part that had been sort of
underground for a long time in the
of social media now is finding that it
could actually Harlan's people and beat
up okay so those and now and you know
and I think the media really fueled both
of those things because basically when
Hillary said that deplorable comment she
just lumped the whole damn thing
together and I think if she had not said
that I think it's very possible she'd be
present how would she help Takashi
almost may they all right exist yeah so
what my question really is how would you
just define the alright flat out if I
asked you right now because I think the
definition has changed that how's it but
if I ask you right now in the summer of
2018
yeah the definition you know the phrase
all right comes about what ten years ago
I think it was coined by Paul Godfrey
himself as a fellow of Kosh man I I
would rather look at this as a writer
galleon collectivist movement you know
and in general that stretches from the
early nineteenth century all the way up
to the present that's the was
characterized by a love of dictatorship
a love of power protectionist trade
policy nativist immigration policy and
and and a resentment against commercial
life because it's because it's it's it's
too heterogeneous into it and nobly in
humanity I mean that to me the alt-right
is one species I guess you could say one
flavoring one instantiation of a much
larger problem that stretches way back
which is an illiberal theory of of life
a liberal theory of politics so that's I
think the right way to think about it
but first time I heard Trump speak was
July 2015 and and I don't even think we
were using the term all right at the
time hmm but he opened his speech with
the immigrants are a problem I thought
hmm then it was protection of their
foreign goods protections when do
protections under that a third big point
was I can fix everything this is all
sounded strangely familiar to me you
know that's that's like the three
pillars of right Hegelian ideology
essentially and I realized we had a
problem and I understand I do why people
had a high regard for him he was gonna
save us from from the problems that
Obama had created
god knows those problems and and the
left has gotten just bonkers right so we
need we need protection from that but he
introduced his own form of problems and
he unleashed its own form of dangers and
potential potentially very despotic
arrangements of power and in some ways
are more insidious because they appealed
to booze Razzie the left has always been
a little bit culturally estranged you
know from the mainstream of American
life with Trump connects very closely
with it this is why fascist movements
have been often times much more
successful than the left socialist ones
wait I gotta I gotta get this because I
would have thought the opposite so if
you if you would have asked me before
you said that I would say the left is
the one that has understood the the
culture part of this at least in the
American piece is certainly academia and
culture what what you could and couldn't
joke about a little turn yeah the left
is as Hayek said you know I mean
socialist ideology never came from below
it's never a working man's philosophy it
was always an until it was always the
intellectual it was a top-down rule
there's always the ruling class that
hatched associate socialist ideology
there never would have been communism
socialism all these things without the
intellectual class but fascism if you'll
allow me to use that term kind of flips
a narrative a little bit it's more it's
much more of a from below you can keep
your religion you can keep your
nationhood your identity your race your
language rally around your friends your
family you know all the things that you
believe are true you and and and and and
and within me as a person as a leader I
will embody all your values and and
collectivize us in a way that that means
something important that that connects
with who you are so in that sense it's
it's a very effective way of being a
liberal all right so all that said what
is our way out of this precarious
position I I think I get where yeah I
get the theme of what you're doing here
I love is we have to just keep fighting
for what we've been doing
better well so Dave I think we need to
rethink who we are I think we need to
deepen and enrich our understanding of
who we are and what we're here to do and
it goes back centuries I mean it was the
liberalism that dug us out of feudalism
that ended the Guild's that brought us
free trade that ended slavery that
really gave birth in modern world and we
need to learn to take credit for that
and make that ethos our ethos go back
and read the works of Adam Smith and the
great Scot Scottish Enlightenment
thinkers you know and and understand our
history so we understand ourselves
better I think this is important because
we need to stop thinking about stuff
even though we are radicals I think you
are I think I am well I almost believe
that we should stop thinking of
ourselves that way we should think of
ourselves as normal if I'm a radical
then the phrase radical it's definitely
not as cool as it used to mean I think
I'm open to these ideas and I I guess
being being open right now and being
really living up to the ideals that
you've set forth here yes is radical
these days yeah it kind of is and maybe
liberalism has always been a radical
Creed because it opposes power it always
has been opposed to power that's what we
have to do now but we also have to
celebrate regular life you know we have
to we have to celebrate the good life
and the beautiful things and the things
we love the people we love and the
choices that we can make and the
technologies we can use a night I fall
in love with the new technology every
single day I came over there I came over
to see you with this new funny pillow
that I bought for $10 on Amazon it
allows me to sleep sitting stayed up I'm
in raptured yeah I think this is the way
to happiness and I think ultimately is
the path to political victory for us to
to be to be more hopeful to be more
cheerful to be more to celebrate life
and celebrate love and celebrate wealth
in a way in which neither the left or
the right are doing right now it gives
us as an opening to be awesome
to emancipate the world we can do this I
got nothing better to do for more on
Jeffrey follow him on Twitter Jeffery a
Tucker
[Music]